[Música]
es difícil encontrar un paisaje más de
ensueño alejadas del mundo y con su
impresionantemente hermoso arrecife de
coral las maldivas son una postal de la
vida real el coronavirus mantuvo
alejados a los visitantes durante meses
pero ahora están volviendo en la capital
vale estos hidroaviones que antes
estaban en tierra ahora vuelven a
despegar llevan a los turistas a los
cientos de centros turísticos de las
islas que componen el archipiélago
con un vuelo cada 10 minutos las
compañías se están recuperando
en este momento tenemos casi 2.500
pasajeros en promedio y antes del cobi
teníamos 2800 así que nos estamos
recuperando poco a poco esta pareja
francesa vino de orleans en el centro de
francia hace dos semanas el empresario y
la diseñadora de gafas reservaron
espontáneamente el viaje de ocho días
necesitábamos un verdadero descanso un
lugar que fuera seguros este es el lugar
ideal para soltar nuestras maletas y
despejar nuestras cabezas
el único requisito para entrar a las
maldivas es tener una prueba pcr
negativa en la isla no hay cuarentena y
los turistas de todo el mundo están
bienvenidos a los visitantes de las
islas balnearias se les anima incluso a
quitarse las mascarillas tan pronto como
se bajan del mar
es como viajar en el tiempo a un mundo
pre kobe el uso de mascarillas no es
necesario porque todos los empleados
viven en el lugar por lo que el riesgo
de infección es limitado las únicas
personas que llegan son clientes que ya
se hicieron la prueba
patri zaira ha dirigido este centro
turístico durante cuatro años los
últimos meses fueron muy angustiosos
para él ahora con el hotel casi lleno
puede respirar con alivio aquí pueden
ver todas nuestras reservas
los números de habitación aquí con los
próximos días y semanas como pueden ver
está más o menos lleno
estamos terminando este mes al 85% de
capacidad
el centro turístico ni siquiera tuvo que
bajar sus tarifas para atraer a los
clientes todos pagan entre 6.500 y 16
mil euros por una semana de estancia con
todo incluido escapar de la pandemia
tiene su precio exclusiva no es barato
pero pienso que es un viaje que se hace
una vez en la vida y este es un buen
momento para hacerlo
más de un cuarto de la economía de las
maldivas depende del turismo casi todo
el mundo vive de este es el caso de atif
al ahmed el instructor de buceo del
centro turístico
lleva mostrándoles a los turistas el
impresionante fondo marino de las
maldivas desde que cumplió 18 años gana
1600 euros al mes sin los que su familia
no sobreviviría
mi familia mis hijos incluso mis padres
viven gracias al dinero que recibo
mensualmente
pero no todos en las maldivas se
benefician del regreso de los turistas
actualmente las excursiones fuera de los
centros turísticos a las islas habitadas
están prohibidas para prevenir posibles
contagios